FORCES TRYING TO SUPPRESS FREE
SPEECH IN OUR LATEST INSTALLMENT
OF "DEFENDING THE FIRST."
YOU DO NOT WANT TO MISS THIS.
WE ARE GOING TO NAME NAMES.
FIRST, WAS THE RAID ON TRUMP'S
PERSONAL ATTORNEY JUST A PROXY
MOVE BY MUELLER IN HIS FISHING
EXPEDITION?
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
DO YOU HEAR THAT DRIP, DRIP,
DRIP SOUND?
THOSE ARE THE NONSTOP LEAKS
COMING FROM THE OFFICES OF THE
U.S. ATTORNEY FOR THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK WHICH ON
MONDAY AS WE KNOW EXECUTED THE
RAID ON THE HOME, THE WORK, AND
THE TEMPORARY RESIDENCE OF TRUMP
LAWYER MICHAEL COHEN.
FROM UNNAMED SOURCES WITH
KNOWLEDGE OF THE INVESTIGATION,
WE LEARNED THAT THE SEARCH
FOCUSED ON DOCUMENTS RELATED TO
PORN STAR STORMY DANIELS AND
POTENTIAL CRIMES MAY INCLUDE
BANK AND WIRE FRAUD ALONG WITH
CAMPAIGN FINANCE VIOLATION.
YESTERDAY THERE WERE MORE LEAKS
THAT INVESTIGATORS WERE SCOURING
FOR INFORMATION RELATED TO, AND
I KID YOU NOT, THE ACCESS
HOLLYWOOD TAPE.
AND A NEW REPORT TODAY IN THE
NEW YORKER ALLEGING POSSIBLE
PAYMENTS TO A TRUMP TOWER
DOORMAN.
AND OTHERS DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
BOTTOM LINE, RIGHT NOW, AS
THINGS ARE, RUSSIAN COLLUSION
SEEMS TO BE A FAINT MEMORY.
AFTER ALL THE HYPE ABOUT THAT
TRUMP TOWER MEETING WITH DON JR.
AND THE RUSSIAN ATTORNEY, ALL
AFTER ALL OF THE "HIDE THE BALL"
TACTICS THE DOJ USED TO APPLY
FOR THE FISA WARRANT.
YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
AFTER ALL THE SPECULATION ABOUT
TRUMP'S RELATIONSHIP WITH
RUSSIA, MUELLER HAS COME UP WITH
GOOSE EGGS.
NOW, TEAM TRUMP IS PROPERLY
WORRIED THAT MUELLER IS JUST
USING THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF
NEW YORK AS A PROXY TO DO THEIR
DIRTY WORK.
IN OTHER WORDS, HAVE THE
NEW YORK AGENTS VACUUM UP A
WHOLE BUNCH OF STUFF IN COHEN'S
FILES ON THE PRESIDENTS PERSONAL
BUSINESS DEALS, ARGUABLY OUTSIDE
THE SCOPE OF THE SPECIAL
COUNCILS JURISDICTION.
AND THEN SHOOT IT BACK OVER TO
US IF IT'S HELPFUL TO OUR CAUSE
AND GOING AFTER THE PRESIDENT.
THAT WAY, MUELLER GETS CREDIT
FOR INITIALLY GOING TO ROD
ROSENSTEIN, DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL, WITH THE
INFORMATION IN THE FIRST PLACE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD DO
WITH THIS?
BUT HE GETS NONE OF THE DOWNSIDE
BY BEING THE GUY WHO EXECUTES
THE SEARCH WARRANT AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL ATTORNEY.
NEVER HAPPENED IN THE HISTORY OF
THE COUNTRY BEFORE.
REMEMBER, LAST SUMMER,
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID THAT THE
EFFORT, ANY EFFORT BY THE FED TO
LOOK INTO HIS PERSONAL FINANCES
IS MM-MM.
>> LOOKING AT FINANCES, YOUR
FAMILY'S FINANCES UNRELATED TO
RUSSIA, WOULD IT BE A REDLINE?
>> I WOULD SAY YES.
>> Laura: THE WHOLE PROCESS IS
TOTALLY OUT OF CONTROL.
THIS IS WHY THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
STATUTE IN MY MIND IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THINK ABOUT IT THIS WAY.
MUELLER'S OFFICE RESIDES WITHIN
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
AND THAT MEANS IF HE WANTS TO
AND IF IT'S POLITICALLY
APPROPRIATE FOR HIM TO DO SO, AS
THEY HEADED THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH, THE PRESIDENT SHOULD BE
ABLE TO FIRE HIM.
BUT IF MUELLER DID GET FIRED BY
TRUMP FOR WHATEVER REASON, ALL
HELL WOULD BREAK LOOSE.
>> FIRING ROD ROSENSTEIN OR
ROBERT MUELLER WOULD PROVOKE A
CONSTITUTIONAL FIRESTORM.
>> NO QUESTION THAT IF
PRESIDENT TRUMP FIRED MUELLER,
ROSENSTEIN, OR EVEN SESSIONS, HE
WOULD SET IN MOTION A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
>> A NEW LEVEL OF CRAZY FOR
TRUMP.
A NEW LEVEL OF BEING OUT OF
CONTROL.
THEY, I THINK FOR THE FIRST
TIME, ARE REALLY PETRIFIED HE'S
GOING TO TAKE THAT STEP AND THEY
WILL BE IN THE MIDST OF A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
>> Laura: AREN'T YOU TIRED OF
THE PONDED ECHO CHAMBER?
THEY KEEP REPEATING THEMSELVES
DAY AFTER DAY.
NO ORIGINAL THOUGHT.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS IS?
WHEN AN UNELECTED AND LARGELY
UNACCOUNTABLE BAND OF
HYPERPARTISAN ATTORNEYS LOYAL TO
THE PREVIOUS PRESIDENT AND MAYBE
EVEN HILLARY CLINTON, THEY ARE
ABLE TO SPEND MILLIONS OF YOUR
TAX DOLLARS IN SEARCH OF A CRIME
MERELY TO UNDO THE RESULTS OF A